♪♪
.
>> Jessica: CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
DEFENDING HERSELF OF THAT POCK
ARREST AFTER WEARING TAX THE
RICH DRESS TO A STAR STUDDED
GALA THAT COST $30,000.
>> OH, MY GOD, TAX THE RUSH,
WHAT A MODEL AOC.
I DIDN'T KNOW YOU MODEL AS WELL.
>> WHEN AURORA AND I WERE FIRST
KIND OF PARTNERED, WE REALLY
STARTED HAVING A CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
WORKING CLASS WOMEN OF COLOR AT
THE MET, AND WE SAID, YOU KNOW,
WE CAN'T JUST PLAY ALONG, BUT WE
NEED TO BREAK THE FOURTH WALL
AND CHALLENGE SOME OF THE
INSTITUTIONS.
AND, YOU KNOW, WHILE THE MET IS
KNOWN FOR ITS SPECTACLE, WE
SHOULD HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
IT.
>> Jessica: OKAY.
SO HOUSEKEEPING FIRST.
SHE DIDN'T PAY FOR THE TICKETS,
SHE DIDN'T PAY FOR THE DRESS.
>> Dana: WHO DID?
>> Jessica: IT WAS DONATED AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT GOES ON.
BUT TODAY EVERYONE IS TALKING
ABOUT IT WHICH WAS THE POINT.
SO DOESN'T AOC JUST WIN?
>> Dana: I GUESS SHE WINS IN
TERMS OF HER GOAL OF FURTHERING
THE CONVERSATION, WHICH SHE DID.
EVERYBODY IS TALKING ABOUT IT.
BUT I ACTUALLY FOUND THIS
INFURIATING AND IT HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH HER DRESS.
IF YOU WATCH THE WAY THAT THESE
ELITES WALKING THE RED CARPET,
THEY ARE WALKING UNABATED.
THEIR FACES ARE OPEN.
THEY GET TO SMILE FOR ALL THE
CAMERAS AND ALL THE WORKING
CLASS PEOPLE SERVING THEM HAVE
TO BE FACELESS, THEY ARE MASKED
AND WE SEE THIS AS A HABIT FOR
THE LEFT.
AND SHE CLAIMS TO BE FIGHTING
FOR THE PEOPLE AND I WATCHED A
VIDEO OF HER HAVING HER TRAIN
CARRIED THROUGH THE CARPET INTO
THE MET BY A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
WORKING THERE WHO WERE MASKED.
WE SAW NANCY PELOSI DO THIS WITH
HERBIG OUTDOOR DINNER WHILE THE
SERVANTS, MANY PEOPLE OF COLOR,
BY THE WAY, YOU KNOW, SERVING
THEM.
WE SAW THIS AT PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
PARTY.
SO THIS IDEA NOW OF THE LEFT AND
THE ELITES ALLOWING THE
PANDEMIC -- THEY'VE NEVER HAD TO
DEAL WITH IT.
THEY ALL FLEW IN ON PRIVATE
JETS, THEY DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT VACCINE MANDATES FOR
COMMERCIAL TRAVEL IF THEY WANT
TO SEE THEORY FAMILY.
BUT THE PEOPLE THEY THINK SERVE
THEM AND WORK FOR THEM, THEY
HAVE TO BE SUB JEW GATED TO
THESE RULES.
SO IT'S NOT ABOUT HER DRESS,
THIS IS ABOUT MARXISM AND
COMMUNISM AT ITS CORE WHICH
MEANS THE ELITES GET TO DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT AND THE
PEASANTS AND LITTLE PEOPLE HAVE
TO SERVE THEM AND OBEY THE RULES
IF THEY WANT TO JUST GO TO WORK
FOR A DAY.
>> Jessica: WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT POINT?
>> Dana: A COUPLE THINGS.
SO SHE IS AOC ANTOINETTE AND
THIS IS A PERFECT EVENT FOR HER
THE CHAMPAGNE SOCIALISTS ALL GET
TOGETHER ONCE A YEAR AND KATIE
THAT IS A VERY GOOD POINT ABOUT
THE WORKING CLASS PEOPLE THAT
WERE THERE.
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS
A LITTLE BIT OF A PROBLEM, AND
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE TAKEN A
DIFFERENT TACT IN THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS THAT THEY'RE MORE
OF THE PARTY OF THE WORKING
CLASS AND YOU MIGHT START TO SEE
A LITTLE MORE IF THE REPUBLICANS
CAN FIGURE OUT OUT HOW TO DO
THIS.
SHE DIDN'T PAY FOR THE TICKET,
THE TICKET WAS DONATED.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE PERSON WHO
DONATED THE TICKET THROUGH THE
NONPROFIT FUNDRAISER DIDN'T
DEDUCT THAT FROM THEIR TAXES?
OF COURSE THEY DID.
AND THEY DIDN'T SHOW UP IN
HYBRID CARS AND GREEN NEW DEAL
VEHICLES.
THEY ARE RIGHT NOW TRYING TO
PASS A $3.5 TRILLION BILL AND
REVERSE ENGINEERING, LIKE IT'S
GOING TO HELP ALL SORTS OF
PEOPLE.
AND THE TRUST IN GOVERNMENT IS
AT SUCH A LOW HE BEEN RIGHT NOW
THAT I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S GOING
TO PASS OR NOT.
THE THING FOR HER IS, SHE KNOWS
HOW TO GET ATTENTION.
SHE DOES IT VERY WELL.
BEAUTIFUL YOUNG WOMAN.
SHE'S GOT A BIG FOLLOWING.
MY LAST POINT IS, I REALLY
RESPECT THE DESIGNER, AURORA
JAMES.
IMPRESSIVE PERSON.
BUT IN HER TWITTER FEED, AOC
SAID THAT SHE WAS AN IMMIGRANT.
OKAY, SHE COMES FROM CANADA.
OKAY?
IT'S NOT LIKE SHE WAS MAKING HER
WAY UP FROM A REALLY TOUGH PLACE
LIKE BANGLADESH OR NICARAGUA.
SHE CAME FROM TORONTO.
>> SHE SPEAKS CANADIAN SO IT
MUST HAVE BEEN REALLY TOUGH.
>> THE OTHER THING ON THAT TOO
IS AOC IS NOT WORKING CLASS.
SHE GREW UP IN A VERY RICH
SUBURB WENT TO BOSTON
UNIVERSITY, WAS A BARTENDER FOR
A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME AND NOW
IS A CONGRESSWOMAN LIVING IN
WASHINGTON, DC, IN ONE OF THE
MOST EXPENSIVE BUILDINGS IN DC
AND LIVES ABOVE THE WHOLE FOODS
AND DRIVES A TESLA.
COME ON.
>> JESSE:.
>> JESSE: BERNIE SANDERS WOULD
HAVE STOOD ACROSS THE STEPS OF
THE GALA WITH A LITTLE PLACARD
THAT SAID TAX  THE RICH AND A
BULL HORN.
THAT'S A PROTEST.
THIS IS A PERFORMANCE.
THIS IS A POP STAR SOCIALIST
TRYING TO GET STREET CRED FOR
THE SLOGAN AND ALSO WANTING TO
HANG OUT WITH CELEBRITIES.
HERE'S HOW IT GOES, ANNA RUNS
THE TOP OF THE MET.
SO SHE SENDS AOC A TICKET, AND
EVERYBODY ELSE, AS DANA SAID,
WRITES THIS OFF AS A TAX
DEDUCTION.
SO AOC GOES, SHE GETS BUZZ, THE
MET GALA GETS BUZZ.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IT.
AND ALL THESE RICH LIBERALS GET
TO FEEL LIKE, YEAH, WE'RE VERT
WITH US, YEAH, SURE, TAX THE
RICH.
AND THEN THE NEXT DAY THEIR
ACCOUNTANTS ARE WORKING 24/7 TO
LOWER THEIR TAXABLE INCOME.
THE FUNNY THING IS AOC WRITES
THE TAX CODE.
SHE'S RAISING AWARENESS?
OKAY, WE KNOW LIBERALS WANT TO
RAISE TAXES ON THE RICH.
WE'VE KNOWN THAT FOR A HUNDRED
YEARS.
SHE COULD WRITE A TAX BILL.
AOC HAS NEVER WRITTEN A BILL
THAT'S GOTTEN OUT OF COMMITTEE
HER ENTIRE CAREER.
SHE DOES NANCY AND CHUCK DO IT
WITH A ROOM FULL OF LOBBYIST
THEY CAR HAVE OUT THE LOOPHOLES
AND THEN THE NEXT CYCLE THE
REPUBLICANS SCAR HAVE OUT THE
LOBBYISTS AND WORK OUT THE
LOOPHOLES.
SHE DOES IT EVERY TIME AND GETS
WHAT SHE WANTS.
>> Brian: RIGHT NOW IF YOU WORK
IN NEW YORK AND YOU HAVE $10 YOU
HAVE TO GIVE AWAY SIX.
HOW MUCH MORE MONEY DO YOU WANT.
61% OF EVERYONE'S INCOME ON THE
BOOKS BETWEEN STATE AND LOCAL
AND CITY TAXES, GOES TO SOMEBODY
ELSE.
AND YET MOST OF THOSE PEOPLE
THAT ARE RICH, VERY FEW
INHERITED IT.
A LOT ARE WORKING 60, 70 HOURS A
WOKE SUPPORTING OTHER PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT WORKING OR WHO WORK
GOVERNMENT JOBS.
THE OTHER THING IS, TO BRING UP,
MAYOR de BLASIO WAS ALSO THERE.
THIS GUY'S POVERTY, A MARXIST
REALLY AGAINST THE RICH AND FOR
THE WORKING CLASS AND HATES COP
AND HANGS OUT WITH THE RICH AND
FAMOUS.
THAT'S WHERE HE'S GOING TO END
UP IN HIS YEARS.
I FIND THE WHOLE THING
DETESTABLE.
BUT I FEEL AS THOUGH THIS IS
GOING TO BE THE PRELIMINARY TO
THE MANSION AOC HEAVY WEIGHT
BOUGHT THAT'S GOING TO BE TAKING
PLACE IN TWO OR THREE WEEKS.
>> I DON'T KNOW, MANSION WAS
DISMISSIVE ON THE SHOWS, HE SAID
WE HAVEN'T SPOKEN I REALLY DON'T
CARE.
>> HE WASN'T AT THE MET EVE